[Music]
I hate the way that I love
you and I need
you I don't want to but I want you yeah
I hate the way that you let's just tell
everyone we're together
what could be kind of
fun there's no way we can convince
anyone we actually like each
other trust me we're at a wedding A
Million Miles Away From Home who knows
what could
[Music]
[Applause]
happen convincing enough I
[Music]
way there's a young
man I talked to him
I wish I just SP
[Music]
you that's really weird
Lisa the
greatest God
crepp on the mission Taffy says it's a
waste of time to try and fix a way it's
better just accept a guys fls oh that's
so cute
[Music]
I can't do that not until we bury the
body there's no turning back
now I can't be
saved and in the next life remember me
remember
[Music]
me really hope this goth phase in
soon
[Music]
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
OA Lumpa Ana what now in fact in Lumpa
land I am regarded as something of a
Whopper they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie woner you see
I'm something of a magician
prepare to be amazed a
t inventor may I present Willy wago's
wild and wonderful wishy washy WKA
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
o he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send Wonka
a message not sell chocolate in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head I love a bonk on the
head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
budhist give them the old one
too I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course run away every good thing in this
world started with a dream
wooo so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world I'm not in premium econ good night
sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke you quite
viciously with a cocktail
stick pressure is all right Gary yeah
that's
perfect is there any area in particular
you want me to focus on today um Gary
how many guys have you done this with
you're the first guy that I've ever been
intimate with I had a wife she left I
really don't know what to say I mean
words of affirmation is not my love
language it's more
like I've been alive for nearly half a
century and I haven't actually lived
even a second of it Gary I'm going to
help you let's find someone for you oh
my God there's so many OD guys I think
that this might just be too much too
late he's already on his way wait
what Hello sup bro just want to get in
and get out oh you can get in all
right it's a gorgeous Landing what are
you doing I'm calling 911 Gary no
accidents happened it was your first
night being gay did you really think you
were going to make any mistake [__] he
bled through the tar that's Mountain
Ashwood it's really porous oh my God
you're so
gay are you a cop no wait are you no
good cuz the dark web's built on trust
come
on is this what it's like this is what
it's like I am like human poppers I open
anyone up I'm really glad I met
you even if multiple people are dead
because of itpp
[Music]
diamond as we Church girls know how to
kneel
it where are you
going I am a cool hot zatty where did
you kill him oh we right outside you
moved the body in the closet you guys
ever seen gong girl dis apart with B
stick
[Music]
[Applause]
Gary
why does the zebra look the way it does
so EMB hey Focus this one no it's
different
now you've been on my mind recently you
keep popping up in my dreams you don't
do anything you're just there so this
specific
person the remarkable nobody I also had
that experience do you have a
picture have you been dreaming about me
have I been dreaming about you
yeah there's like a 100 messages
somebody wants to interview me this is
strange maybe you should take a minute
and think before you do anything
[Music]
drastic why me uh I don't know I'm
special I
guess how does it feel to go viral who's
actually had a dream about
me
[Music]
you're scaring me but I'm going to have
nightmares I wish I was the one people
were dreaming about me too yeah no it's
it's something how's he dealing with all
this we're not even the type of people
that like attention you know you think
other people are seeing you naked maybe
thousands I hope I'm behaving through
your dreams Oh no you're not so I'm
finally cool huh I didn't say that you
hear that Janet she's saying I'm a cool
dad
really feel like you're playing with
fire
here Z please help me I'm not actually
doing anything to
them you know Fame can come with some
less desirable side effects you should
be prepared for that maybe we should
cool this thing off what what do you
mean it's embarrassing which
partam I guess I'll uh guess I'll see in
my dreams yeah of course
[Music]
not do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you're put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the
universe me neither but you know one can
hope
right wave to Mommy cuz she'll hate me
even more than she does if you don't I
seem to recall you saying that becoming
a lawyer would only crush your soul yeah
it has I'm running a business and right
now that business is getting a
journalist in an
palonia no it's a one-off no no and no
who's a journalist I have resigned my
position here Notting 20 grand says you
are welcome to palon president Vega so
nice to meet
you you must take a self um you
approved
great ow what the hell just happened
you're one man's security detail happen
he's a hero I'm with the president of a
country in the middle of a coup this is
the scoop of a lifetime you got to be
alive to have the scoop of a lifetime we
never should have come let's go you
can't just leave
him
run
run ready to I don't know how to stop
when you start at the bottom only way to
go is up I'm just doing my
job do you need help I get up again man
I got to win I get up again and I got
the win what nothing you still excited
to cover a coup less and less
honestly where is
vas here is Vegas go for hey not the
time for coaching
man oh my
God Color Me impressed Mr Petit not
Petit at
all tell me you got that run you see me
fight
well hello baby girl how are you today
so good it's Christmas Eve oh yeah that
your child loves Christmas just have fun
christmase Christmas Dad isn't that nice
sound like wounded
ducks and what was
that do you mind telling me what you're
doing in my chimney can you see me
what's your name my name is Nicholas
Santa
Claus what is this oh the carrot the M
said I need to eat healthier so she
think this will Wing me off the cookies
has worked so far if you're really Santa
tell me what Charlotte wants for
Christmas she wants a pretend makeup kit
and scooter he's right see Dad I've
never met an 8-year-old girl that did
not want a pretend makeup
set man who are they it looks like
snowman an elf and a nutcracker AKA
every Tuesday at my house got a dash yes
hold no what is going on those bad guys
are acting my naughty and Nic list but I
got some Associates Here Eddie a none
lead really oh claustrophobic I'm sorry
what claustrophobic fear of Santa Claus
that's
ludicrous I get it you don't believe but
I have to deliver Christmas gifts
tonight Dad we need to help him where
are you guys we it Santa Claus and heats
glitter and there's these people and
they aren't actually El bring my child
why don't I should have a white beard i
d it if I want to look younger I deserve
that how can these two out Fox us out
run us all I want to do is a heavy start
believing
again what you about to witness is a
sleigh being pulled by eight beautiful
rain
de this Miss Paar the
Bluetooth who do you work for some
people think I work for mother nature or
father time recently everybody thinks I
work for Beyonce but no every married
man would understand this I work for Mrs
[Music]
Claus ladies and gentlemen of the
jury
how y'all doing for all of y'all that
don't know who I am my name is Willie
Gary willly Gary Wily Gary William Gary
never heard of him what's so special
about this guy
anyway litigation is war it's a battle
bam and I'm not talking about no
[__] either I'm talking about some
Jean CLA bamn ass kicking [__] truth is
I may have got myself into a lot of
trouble I've been your lawyer 30 years
we can find a way out of it you've never
sued anybody before in your whole life
St tried to bully me out of business and
I don't think I should be expected to
stand for white Mr Gary hasn't lost a
case in over 12 years you suggesting I
hire this guy's one of my lawyers y'all
come on in pleasure to meet you Mr Gary
let me introduce you to my call how do
you feel about working with black folk I
suppose I am a little Prejudice did you
meet my team I'm Chris the dougas chlen
he's suing us he's suing us we are a
half a billion dollar Corporation so how
much money y'all trying to get 8 million
that ain't enough money $100 million
[Laughter]
who is this clown he's hired as a
lawyer you fight man what made you want
to do cuz he tried to mess with the one
thing that means the most to me in life
being able to leave something behind for
my
grandchildren let's play some
music my name is Maine DS graduated top
of her class from Harvard Law School
they had a nickname for her around the
office the python I wouldn't get too
used to me being kind to you Mr Gary
once we begin that
trial I'm going destroy
you we don't have a snowballs chance in
hella win in this case just just trust
me okay I I I may have found something
what does it feel like to be some small
time nobody on the verge of
bankruptcy what if I don't win and I let
all these people down you have been
trying to turn this into your own one
ring circus I got my damn life on the
line I know that Jerry
did it ever bother you the hypocrisy the
hypocrisy you sit your ass down your
honor he hey wait wait what we can't
split the pole can't split the pole now
come
on
now dear
Edith you foxy ass old [__]
carry
on you really are a trixy old
[__] and you're sad stinky pitch in
the end I think it's just
jealousy I think we know who it is love
our neighbor and I tried but I'll get
you in the ball sa she's heinous Edith I
didn't do it I believe we may be
charging an innocent a woman police
officer oh look Flying Pig I've got a
daughter at home why would I risk it all
you want [__] in the nose holes you
old beetle beetle
right if you meddle in my case these
will be on your
wrists in prison Rose may find some
Kindred Spirits in prison no no not the
murders or the rapists I'm thinking more
the drunks and the queers maybe just
trying to find a bright
side hey you da all [__] slippery or
[__]
Dodger why would I send a letter when I
can just say
it I probably say that you look like
[__] Queen Victoria sh a [__]
netop or [__] [__] I don't know you
s coming [__] and the cakes you make
look like they falling out some [__]
sh [__] [__]
better I have a
plan will catch them in the
ACT what would your husband think my
husband is in a liary so he's not
thinking a great
deal
I like hero I
hater you don't like the idea of me
leaving this house do you I'm going to
lose her we're not standing for it I had
one now
everyone is going to
know it's
[Music]
German
[Applause]
[Music]
I
d
they spent what a trillion dollars
trying to get one dude back from Mars if
you get the opportunity to bring back
Matt Damon I just don't think we should
wait around to be saved you know you
really don't think they're sending
anybody to save us I
[Music]
mean in case you haven't noticed we're
doomed to spend the rest of our
miserable lives on this ship maybe we
should do it do what it
we're not attracted now but we would
emotionally attach you mean fall in love
what if this awesome thing we have going
on gets ruined people are meant to be
together oh sorry is this is this on
okay
lame we're both married I'm sure being a
drift in space gives you a h
pass need I want the sun days before
stuck inside rning out to you know what
you want to watch tonight alien never
seen
it why the hell did we watch that
[Music]
movie how did you come to write this
book what really struck me was that too
few books were about my people where are
our stories where's our representation
would you give us the pleasure of
reading an
excerpt yo surara girl you be pregnant
it again if I is Ray Ray is going to be
a real father this time
around thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you Monk your books are good but they're
not popular editors they want a black
book they have a black book I'm black
and it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they publish look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses it
I be standing outside in the night dead
be dads rappers crack you said you
wanted black stuff that's black right I
see what you're
doing we sold your book no we believe Mr
Lee has written a bestseller it's a joke
the most lucrative joke you've ever told
now is stag a pseudonym yeah Mr Lee
can't use his real name is this based on
your actual life
yeah you think some [__] ass college
boy can come up with that [__] no no no
I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that not me they ran
300,000 copies pebooks change people's
lives they're offering $4 million for
moving rights yes the Dumber I behave
the Richer I
get this has gone too far stag Arley is
still on the Run authorities you haven't
done anything it's not like they can
arrest
you it wish I could go back to not
selling books is it bad to cater to
people's taste people want to love you
Monk you should let them love all of you
there's already so much Buzz because of
the movie deal Michael beat Jordan a
circly we want to put them on the cover
in one of those um scarves I guess you
would call them tied around his head a
doag doag that's it dag in a tank top
with the muscle showing somebody called
the fire
department
we're thinking we can get it out in
h is that yes it
is what the hell were you doing you're 3
hours late dad you don't understand the
car was busted so we had to shred why
your lips red were you eting a snow cone
it's a really good guess what kind of
adults rer Blade the police are here and
they're saying that you bought alcohol
for minors thanks Boys in Europe the
drinking age is like 10 they could have
been European what made you think they
were European they had a certain genesa
quality I think one of them was eating
pent on
shakala guys everyone thinks we're
losers but that's about to
change I know where The Treasure of
Foggy Mountain is from when we were kids
we are looking at 100 Mil $100 million
it'd be like I mean I know it's more
than this but at least a million dollar
each significantly more what are we
waiting for
the cute guys that came in earlier I
didn't see nobody cute the ginger look
like a colonial ghost glasses look like
Tim Burton Drew him and in a short one
we probably with a same siiz bra they
had a treasure map with like an x on it
we going to steal that map that is a
full on Hawk hey buddy Traverse ite
the does it not know it can fly why did
it walk away with an attitude everyone
is after this treasure we deserve that
you deserve it yeah three white guys
whose biggest issue is what growing up
no feel like it's more nuanced than
that you just hit a woman I apologize
for him I for one would never oh oh my
God so I've one woman that's not in the
grand welcome new friends we can all
agree this is a scary cult and we're
waiting for the other shooter drop we're
in a docu series and this is episode two
dude
completely insane night guys why are we
tied
up I'd rather die than live without you
boys
holy
oh guys look dude that's that's the
treasure door open
it what I would be sick I would be sick
to my stomach forget the money it's not
worth it
[Music]
I need your brace amount of reindeer
what why are you like this thank you so
much
baby a lot of spice wow Merry Christmas
oh sh what's Christmas without a little
tear check that list twice was your
Christmas
wish I just wanted to be the best
ever oh ignore all the fine print
honestly it's like you're signing your
life
away this is
crazy hold up that was your wish not
like I don't know world peace in hunger
and homelessness stop climate change St
the polar bears new Drake album oh I
love Drake point take
it oh my God oo look at you high stuff
looking like a t drink of water I'm
enchanted I don't understand why you
have to formally invite your parents you
know they're coming invite here they
love that she went with antique Sage is
that the more expensive one our one and
only daughter is getting married do not
talk to me about right now I still think
they should have
justo Marshall you think I should give
him a plus one he's your man of Honor if
he's single he'll come stag otherwise
he'll bring someone but what if he
brings Marie welcome
TOA lizard you're getting married can
you believe
it
surprise this place is perfect no I I'm
too dignified of a man to be on the
beach I specifically wrote plus one
anyone but Marie James I mean I just
don't understand how someone else can
book the bridal Suite during someone
else's wedding it's me I'm the bride
there a week can trade no marshmallow he
said we can have the better room are you
that woman is a disaster I have to do
special brownies for my sister to fake
as much pot in the batter as possible
pot the most important day of our lives
and you were asked to bring anyone
anyone except
Marie oh God I can't believe you just
stole a trolley what are you doing with
my wedding press on get this party
started got to get
a
what did you put in those
brownies heaby somebody need a epip
pen we should really respect nature no
wait it's on my hand it's on my
hand get the bride and groom raise your
glasses to the bride and groom y'all
should
[Music]
heo look at this place anemone the sun
is shining everybody's out there having
fun fun makes you want to get out there
and join them doesn't it well I'll see
[Applause]
you now do not forget you are the help
they are the guest your spriter has
arriv finally you got to get out of your
shell buddy come on Army I'm not like
these other crabs all right I don't
throw my claws in the
air I don't wave them like I just don't
care wakey this is for your own good AR
but when
you ask D what you got move girl what
did you say to me no no no no no no that
wasn't me that was uh him him who me me
me oh he's so
cute hey look
out aren where are you aren how far are
we from the ocean in in Crab leges I
don't know maybe a million this may be
the furthest away from my mother I've
ever been wooo it feels amazing girl
have you lost your
mind oh this my
jam How You Like Me
Now how you doing you know lost and
afraid for my life other than that can't
complain come on open your eyes I liked
it better when they were shut what are
you doing
[Music]
kid
it is good to see you out of the house
Army what do you think they'll think of
us oh
snap are you finished yet c crab cuz
you're standing and not drinking
water that was class sorry that was my
fault are you okay you just had Zach
McLaren's ball in your face what's this
GPA you have any books on battle toads
you know video games are now the leading
cause to divorce Could you actually
order me a book on that really no
sarcasm is frequently an attempt to
deflect one's ignorance so being to know
it all oh wait you forgot your credit
card
hey oh my God what's up do the heck h a
car now he has a concussion and he
thinks it him his girlfriend thank God
it's you oh no all right he is dating
his Zoe what other Zoe he's either dead
or he's dumbed to me honestly I'm not
sure which is worse make sure Zach takes
it easy his symptoms could get worse
what I do you don't want him getting
worse pretend to be the other Zoe you've
been dating 2 or 3 weeks now
right
Yep this is Zach's cousin miles he's in
grad school at MIT oh my God a match for
Zoe I caus the accident and now I'm
going to flirt with an Amnesia patient's
cousin we're all going to go skiing in
the mountains this weekend you want to
go with us strip of land seven letters
Christ how did you know that well done
you two should we hit slums we should
CH it's confusing I'm enjoying getting
to know you over again go they a swing
at
life you and Zach do you really think
it's you're a good match like we are
it's
complicated we need to tell him the
truth you have to go after what you want
and be
brave oh my God you're just giving me
wrong com advice now no it's so fun
[Music]
so what did you do did you have fun what
didn't we do excuse me All PG-13
[Music]
okay
holy I will tell you I've never seen
anything like it
holy is the the craziest I think I've
ever seen everything
okay $1 million what are you going to do
get a Ferrari what the oh language the
baby's
here yo what up everybody royan Kitty
here I'm going to pick a stock and talk
about why I think it's interesting and
that stock is Gamestop I love this
guy retail Traders hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it's looks like there's one
guy driving all the buying who is this
SM dumb money man happy to take
it Wall Street is betting that this
company is going to fail if it fails
these hedge funded people make a ton of
money 70,000 people have watched this
video titty I love
you if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
gam Stop Those shares not stopping stop
it's only going to go up when they hit
I'm going to buy you a mansion that's
bring to that my brother is a nerd Wall
Street must be seeing this right you
should probably dial in holy [__] do you
have a minute I uh
um babe how much did we make
today 5 million how much did we lose
today a billion and yesterday 4 million
and yesterday a
billion bab yeah we're like really
rich them
win you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the GameStop
situation retail Traders always lose
you've been served Wall Street
cheated surprise surprise you have to
testify before Congress the game has
[Music]
changed what's the point of winning the
race if you let some idiot steal the
price a lot of people feel the system is
broken the whole idea of the stock
market is if you're smart and maybe with
a little luck you can make your fortune
certainly not
anymore there's no hope for the little
guy [__]
balls maybe now there is
[Music]
yeah guys honestly I don't know what I'm
going to do work as a nightmare my boss
hates me and I'm this close to exploding
this
I mean honestly it just sounds like you
really need to get
laid all right everyone repeat after me
fun and female
[Music]
bonding what brings you and your gang up
here she's cooking at a food festival
this is so
fancy did you book a cabin or dollhouse
it's what it says at least we have
shutters the girls took me away for the
weekend did you ask if I was okay with
this no Mary you can't let him speak to
you like that he's really upset you know
we had plans this weekend like what
sucking his teeny peen and making him
steak
Boo this Festival is a pressure cooker
can you guys just get it together for 5
minutes why don't we try some pranama
breaths okay you know the only reason we
are here is for
you you are so far up your career's ass
that you can't let anyone else in
struggle is normal it's part of
life you have to show up for the people
around around you and
trust that they've got your
[Music]
[Applause]
back
[Music]
okay
yes hi I have some bad news we lost your
mom what sorry that was terrible
phrasing I meant we don't know where she
is oh I think your sister's here Annie
It's finally happened oh my God it's
okay it's okay I'm here we're or oh my
God you're Orphan Annie she's not dead
she ran away the [__] and yum your Mom
owes me 80 grand when you have it you'll
get your dog back I don't have any you
can s your eggs it's not like you're
using them no there has to be another
way what is the square root of 196 14
correct how many hearts does an octopus
have three correct what saffron Saturn
Aphrodite Apollo Aries carbon dioxide
the equal sign correct oh my God what
you know this game this is how you're
going to make the money I'm taking you
to the quiz look
out Le not a drive racist oh
hi come on it's going to be fun I'm not
sleeping on the floor I'm not sleeping
on the floor either I sleep on the chair
I don't want to sleep in a sitting
position oh my
God I can't play on live TV in front of
millions of people let you get to it and
know you got to get through hair and
makeup I already went through hair and
makeup well and you missed a spot I
can't do this am I sing yeah you know
what put your arms down you're having a
panic attack doctors prescribe these is
that
cocaine I Ste IIA do do you ever use
Stevia the sweetener yeah yeah I've got
it in my
pocket win or lose we'll do it
together that is definitely broken I bet
you I could pop it back in my son no I
can't I'm going to
[Music]
throw how can I ever thank you maybe
like a drink later well I'm married and
gay why did you have to say two reasons
[Music]
we are going to make boy band history
tonight bro you're making baby Branch
nervous I feel like I'm going to barf
and pass out and pee your pants all at
once how' you know give it up for
[Applause]
[Music]
froo you suck my exquisitely chiseled
rockard abs and I quit Branch we're out
of sink we've gone from Boys to Men and
now there's only one direction for us to
go the back streets bye see you
later granch what oh hey are you all
right you're smiling and crying at the
same time it kind of looks like it's
hurting your face it does hurt my
face oh baby Branch I'm John Dory
Branch's brother what ow former brother
drama cor me
dink it's hard to say I'm sorry a
brother is a friend who can never leave
you it's the strongest bond in the world
I would kill to have a sibling to sing
with check out your old outfits puffy
jacket pcell necklaces denim tuxedo did
you have frosted tips look at you you
are so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic Branch our brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison there's only
one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner permit
it was a dty McMahon face the better
question is are you a
narc who comes
there we're here looking for our
[Music]
brother oh my gosh
hello my name is Viva it is so fantastic
amazing to see other
tr did you just braid my hair you're
welcome it looks so good I love it is
your dad King Peppe uh yeah Poppy I'm
your sister my what w hey man am I the
only one without a long lost sibling
this is your second chance with your
brothers
Branch b b maybe a smaller diaper if
this diaper was any smaller I could
taste it I know you think it's risky and
maybe it is but it'll be worth it
family's always worth it I ever I can't
believe this is really happening I
[Music]
ever we still got it looks like your
days aren't behind
you I'm going to make it kiss the sky
tonight the cas
Santos not on your
life hello oh
girls it's the last body shot
competition so we are going to Salt you
up I've had it with love I don't believe
it's relevant to the 21st century
lesbian you're not wearing that I just
came from work I came from Toledo I
don't dress like it I'm not here to
Pedal my
wees I'm leaving town I am too that was
my plan where are you going Tallahasse
Florida I've been unhappy that's why we
take this trip together honey babe we
get our act together together ear's
driveway Pan's most trusted nam in car
delivery curly here don't call me
curly and your name curly my name is
Curly we just met it's too
familiar we're here from the car wait a
minute you call with a drop off in
Tallahassee and then these broads come
in and say they're ready to go to
Tallahassee they drive the car instead
of you is that bad bad if they find the
goods what we should see what's in here
bet it's
[Music]
[Applause]
locked I understand that you're unhappy
sir we will find and deliver the package
we just want your
friends you cannot relate to the public
which in the service profession is a big
handicap did the two creeps find you
they know we have their stuff maybe we
sell it back shake them down are they
like wanted or something oh no they're
not in trouble at all I'm going to help
you break a big murder case that is
about the dumbest thing I've ever heard
and I'm a
cop who are you
Democrats wellow youve had a full
day
it's known as the beautiful game but
let's face it it's a complicated game
guys soccer as you like to call it is
like life next season I think we have a
real shot I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody
tell you you're you're
fired good news is you got two options
option one that's where you're currently
at or American SAR are you serious if
you're all
with the
pretty take chance on me we haven't
scored one goal in the history of our
country trying to have a soccer team go
let's scored again humiliation mark my
words things are going to change I got
as a new
[Music]
coach something a drink with whiskey
beer wine yep we got all those which one
whiskey beer and
wine it's safe to say you have zero
Talent OR understanding of the
game something not right about this guy
well he is
white Coach you got the toughest job on
the
island what we won was just one goal one
goal come on guys we've worked too long
and hard for this you've only been here
a few
days what the I can't work with these
guys for them it's like some sort of
game it is a game
Thomas that's it Chia leadership now
we're making some
progress dear Lord thank you for sending
us Mr rongan we've become quite attached
to him it's like finding a little lost
white kid at the mall and telling him
which way to
[Music]
go sir I don't understand that's
glaringly apparent I can't fail this
class oh don't sell yourself short Mr
coats I truly believe that you
can every year at Barton Academy
students faculty and staff depart the
campus for a 2E winter break but there
are always an unfortunate few who have
nowhere to go for the holidays they're
known as the holdovers Mr Han hello Mary
I had you got stuck with babysitting
duty this year how'd you manage that you
know he used to be a student right yeah
that's why he knows how to inflict
maximum pain on
us I thought all the Nazis were hiding
in Argentina stifle it
Telly you just earned yourself a
detention sir being here with you is
already one big detention son of a [__]
that's another detention do you think I
want to be babysitting you no I was
praying your mother would pick up the
phone or your father would arrive in a
helicopter or a flying saucer
dead you don't tell a boy that's been
left behind at Christmas that nobody
wants him what's wrong with you there's
nobody here okay you stay out of my way
and I'll stay out of yours let me
sleep now most of the kids dislike you
pretty much hate you teachers too you
know that right I find the world a
bitter and complicated place and it
seems to feel the same way about me I
think you and I have this in
common I don't think I've ever had a
real family Christmas like this before
thank you Mary you're welcome history is
not simply the study of the past it is
an explanation of the present see when
you say it that way and throwing in some
pornography it's a lot easier to
understand no matter what you
are I'd like to propose a toast to my
two unlikely
companions
and are you trying to Li down my
shirt
no yes you're going to get me
fired this is your Rubicon do not cross
the
Rubicon the
[Music]
holdovers
he